pablo escobar is a name without
forgotten how is that a name known to
many
as the world's most notorious infamous
drug lord in a new book however his
firstborn son tells his own story
roberto sandoya escobar
was rescued as a baby following a
shootout in which
his mother died adopted by an mi6
agent he never knew his true identity
until he was
uh 24 i mean those are the ingredients
are already of a quite extraordinary
story
that have been documented by roberto who
joins us now to talk about the book uh
welcome to roberto thanks so much for
joining us today surrounded by
some of the artworks that now occupy you
you're you're a fine art artist aren't
you but you've found time to write this
book
uh i scarcely know where to begin let's
start at the beginning when you were uh
when you're a baby not even a young
child you were a baby
and this is what the mid 60s tell us
what happened
so obviously as a child baby you don't
you don't remember all these things
what we're actually talking about here
is a situation where
later on my adopted father the mi6 agent
has to tell me who i am and um that is
obviously a
a dreadful shock to me and um
i asked him what these vague you know
nightmare memories were that i was
experiencing as a baby and described
them to him and then
he obviously came clean with what had
happened to me
yeah i mean i guess in the in the mid
60s he he wasn't the sort of
colossus of the crime world that he
became i mean this was somebody who
yeah yeah so so effectively
um colombia was full of gangs uh you
know similar to gangs we have today in
inner cities really
and um a young pablo escobar was a
member of one of these gangs and
unfortunately
they decided to uh take it upon
themselves to
rob one of the armored cars of the uh de
la rue uh
operation in colombia which led to uh
a special forces raid on the hideout of
the gang where they got the money back
unfortunately there was a young lady in
the back room and she'd copped a bullet
and
she was only 14 and there was a baby in
the cot
and this is all the stuff that dad told
me later and he was with her when she
died
and he's promised to look after her baby
boy
and the boy was roberto cindy escobar
but
you know i didn't know any of this
really until i was much older
yeah and tell us about the involvement
of this the mi6
agent who was working with colombian
special forces because
you know he could have completed his
operation and just moved on
yes so effectively um he's got two jobs
one he's um you know managing director
of thomas de la rue
colombia they're printing banknotes and
transporting the money in armoured car
service business and
but that turns out to be his sort of
cover life uh story story and actually
he's doing a secret operation
and working with manuel noriega who was
working with the cia at the time before
he became
military dictator of panama and they're
working on this operation
to infiltrate these gangs and it turns
out that they sort of make
uh one of the uh chaps in the one of
these gangs um the king as it were
something that they do all around the
world you know with saddam hussein and
all this so
they did it then and um it turns out
that in fact this guy
also turned out to be my uh
but um there's a lot of intrigue and
interest in the book that will tell you
how all this came about and he did
become a kind of kingpin
i mean not just any kingpin i mean 80 at
one stage
it's reported 80 percent of the world's
global trade
in cocaine was organized by pablo
escobar
yes yes and it's one thing selling the
cocaine then you get all the money and
it's all in dollars and
in what you do with that you know um
this guy's a hoodlum with no education
and how does he become
you know the world's greatest drug lord
you know uh you know that narcos starts
off
with the assumption that he's a drug
dealer and successful and all the rest
of it but
my story tells the world how it all
began
and how this thug got help so that he
did become that great uh
you know drug lord that he's he's been
portrayed as in the movies
uh you say thug i mean clearly a certain
degree of brutality
must be required you know to to to
prosecute a criminal career to the
extent
which you know in quotes successfully he
did
uh i wonder if opportunities and
circumstances have been different
whether he may have been a successful
businessman or
or something else or or whether he was
just a very bad man
no well i mean it is all about nature
and nurture
and and there's no doubt that you know
the opportunities arose for him and he
was helped by by these uh you know
grown-ups if you like and and i won't
say pat whitcomb didn't help him uh to a
certain degree so they could infiltrate
the businesses they wanted to track
um of course and that's part of the
secret operation and
you know these agents do have to cross
the line to get him into these
organizations but
you're right in saying that you know it
is possible you go one way or the other
and
interesting enough as you can see i'm an
artist for my work
interestingly enough that although my
half brother and i don't know each other
and
frankly we don't get on very well either
um the fact is that we've grown up
completely separate lives and we both
end up doing drawing for a living
so that's quite interesting so so it
just goes to show what you're saying is
right it is possible
you go left or wrong right and you know
you just don't know which way you're
going to end up there's a there's a lot
of nature in there
to get along with the nurture isn't
there and i know he so you
you the mi6 agent takes you under his
wing you go to an english
school for a while uh you know you get
set on this completely different
trajectory
pablo escobar tried to make contact with
you is that correct
yes well no contact was made by
my adopted father and all the
complicated business arrangements that
are discussed in the book
far too long to go into at the moment
but um the
book will describe to you how it is they
infiltrated the cartels and how they got
the trust of this one chat
and they used to take me to medellin and
i remember it as clear as day you know
and i used to have to sit next to him
and
you know he would talk to me and stuff
like that i remember his smell of
cologne and hashish and
you know all that sort of stuff but um
yeah we did used to have to go and see
him
or have to i was told to go and see him
and i was flanked by my bodyguards i
felt okay but
i was confused and you know i didn't
know what was going on i was very young
child and
and uh you know these were just sort of
things that i had to do because the
grown-ups told me to do it
but as you rightly say i got settled in
england and then
later i i was told what this was all
about
and do you remember roberto when when
you heard that he'd been killed in this
shootout in what was in 1993
yes yes so 93 was a very bad year for me
my wife died of cancer unfortunately and
left me with the two kids and
uh my father died my adopted father had
been to karachi on
bcci business you know bringing down
that now
tracking money from the cartels and it's
very complicated but
effectively um 93 was a terrible year
and at the end of the year i'm watching
the news in sunny wolf and on thames in
surrey
and i see that you know the guy that my
dad had been telling me about has been
shot in the head and
and so yes very frightening and i
spiraled after that into a very bad
period of depression and
this is why i it took me you know over
20 years to write this book
i tell you what roberto people write
books with about one percent of the
interest value of your life story that
you tell us or are going to be telling
us in this book
absolutely incredible and just one final
thought i know you you as an artist
you're known as
as philip whitcomb which name do you
prefer to go by one that tells the story
of your life although
yes i've got okay you know it's
basically i've got two nights
two lives and two names it's not not a
problem uh
i've been called a lot worse than
philippines
we very much appreciate you joining us
today with your story thanks so much
thanks a lot